hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
mass spectrometry past and present
emerging
technologies and strategies for quality
management in today's clinical
laboratory
presented by dr sagade dr orton and dr
boyd from alberta precision laboratories
i'm benjamin dugas global senior
marketing manager for clinical
diagnostics at waters corporation
and i'll be your moderator for today's
events
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by waters corporation
for more information on our clinical
solutions please visit
us at watters.com forward slash clinical
at waters we understand that clinical
diagnostics is more than collecting data
it's making a difference in someone's
life
this is why we provide clinical lcm sms
solutions
that you can trust is every step of the
way
now let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time that you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them in the ask a
question box
and click on the send button
additionally
we'll be conducting a few polls and
appreciate your participation
in fact we're going to send out the
first pull now
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
that offers continuing educational
credits
so following this presentation those
credits can be obtained by clicking on
the tab at the right
top right and follow the process to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now introduce our three
presenters from alberta precision
laboratories
dr sazaday is currently the clinical
section chief of biochemistry at alberta
precision laboratories as well as the
clinical professor of pathology and
laboratory medicine
at the university of calgary dr
sazadeh is a widely recognized clinical
chemists and scientists who has offered
authored over 220 peer-reviewed articles
book chapters model graphs abstracts
and co-editor of a book he also directs
clinical projects aimed at developing
new product
markers and methods using lcm sms
technology of which he has implemented
in different laboratories in the past 20
years
dr orton is a clinical biochemist
overseeing the mass spectrometry testing
laboratory in calgary for alberta
precision laboratories excuse me
as well as an assistant professor at the
university of calgary
his current research involves the
development of lcm sms
assays to elucidate a greater
understanding of individuals responses
to drug therapy and pharmacokinetics
dr boyd is a clinical biochemist at
alberta precision laboratories
and clinical associate professor at the
university of calgary
she is the co-director of the analytical
toxicology laboratory which includes
mass spectrometry testing for urine
drugs of abuse therapeutic drug
monitoring
and endocrine markers for a complete
biography on
all of our presenters today please visit
the biography tab
at the top of your screen so with that
i'd like to hand it over to our
presenters to start the present
presentation
uh dr uh sanji
thanks man hello everybody
in this presentation we will discuss the
history of mass spec
compare the strength and weaknesses of
different
types of mass spec and understand
the necessary quality metrics
required to ensure
assay quality and meeting
the standards the first
part of this presentation will cover
a brief review of the history of mass
back
many scientists had significant impact
on the development of mass spec
however due to limited time
today i will not be able to acknowledge
the work of all of them so i will
briefly describe
the work of some of the key contributors
to this field
although it was originally used
in the field of physics more than a
century ago
mass spec has revolutionized the
practice
of laboratory medicine in the past
two decades mass spec is an extremely
powerful technology
that can identify and quantify
any molecule by ionizing that molecule
and measuring the mass to charge ratios
of its generated ions mass spec
is currently the most specific
and sensitive technique in clinical
laboratory
and mass effect will continue to
positively
impact the practice of laboratory
medicine
in all its disciplines history of mass
spec
starts with joseph john thompson a
physicist
who was given an outstanding opportunity
at the famous cavendish laboratory
at cambridge university in england
he was a 28 year old brilliant
theoretical physicist who for the first
time
was given an experimental position
in that excellent institution
at that time transmission of electricity
through gases was a hot
topic and thompson chose that topic
for his research and his assistant
e everett was extremely
important and had significant role
in successful completion of the
experiments
in that laboratory in 1890
thompson measured charge to
mass ratio of some atoms
please note that early physicists
reported charge to mass ratio
not mass to charge ratio as we
currently do two years after that
discovery
thompson built an instrument that could
measure
not only charge over mass
but also charge simultaneously
and therefore he was able to measure the
mass of electrons
thompson received nobel prize in physics
for discovering electrons in
1906. here
you also see the picture of aston
one of thompson's associates
which i will describe his work in next
slides
the early work by thompson laid the
foundation
for the field of mass spec thompson and
his protege
francis william aston in 1919
built the first aspect to measure the
mass
of charged ions
aston was able to identify 212
of 287
naturally occurring isotopes
by the mass effect at that time
which was quite an accomplishment
he continued to improve his mass spec
resolution and by 1927
aston's mass spec was accurate
to more than one part in ten thousand
aston himself received nobel prize
in chemistry in 1920
you can see the neon 20
and 22 ions at the
lower right corner and here
is the picture of the replica
of the third mass spec made by
thompson in early 1940s
an electrical engineer from
physics department at the university of
minnesota
by the name of alfred near
started his significant contribution
to this field by simply bringing
this technology meaning mass
spectrometry
to other scientists near was a modest
gentleman
and ready to share his knowledge with
other scientists
he built several major instruments
including 60 degree sector
field mass spec and with
e.j johnson he built the near johnson
massback
near also helped biologists by
preparing c13
enriched carbon for them to use as
tracer he measured lead isotope for
geochemist so they can determine the age
of the earth
near also contributed to manhattan
projects by separating uranium-235
from uranium-238 or
in the co-furniture
as you know enrico fermi was a top
scientist for manhattan projects
in early 1940s physicist physicists did
not know
which uranium isotope was responsible
for neutron fission near was able to
separate few nanograms of
uranium 35 isotopes
and then he sent that to john
donning's laboratory at columbia
university
and the professor donnings was
able to confirm that uranium 235
was indeed the isotope responsible
for fission and can be used to make
atomic bomb
up to 1940 mass effect was
mostly used by physicists
and industrial chemists no one really
tried to understand what went on
inside that black box in
mid 1950s three chemists
started to use mass spec in their
research
and tried to better understand
this technology
focused on the mass spec instrumentation
and methodology he established
the rules and languages of mass spec
with compounds of known structure
plus demon from mit
used mass spec on alkaloids and
peptides and was among the very first to
show that mass effect can be used to
identify
the structure of unknown complex
natural compounds
called gerasi was an established
scientist at stanford university
who focused mostly on steroids
and terpenoids and came to
the field of mass effect later than the
other two gentlemen in uh 1960 jurassic
invited
professor demon to go to stanford
and help him set up a mass spec
and continued his research on
steroids using mass spec after that
it wasn't until the 1980s that
mass spec was used in the clinical
laboratory
1981 a military plane
crashed on an aircraft carrier and the
pilot's urine tested positive
for marijuana in response to that
accident president reagan enacted
a zero tolerance for drugs of abuse
in the military which then required
testing
at that time drugs of abuse were tested
by
immunoassays immunoassays
in general are not very specific
and can generate paul's positive results
that must
be confirmed by a mass spec
assay and at
in 1980s gas chromatography mass
spectrometry
was mostly in clinical toxicology lab
thus this requirement of testing for
and confirming the positive results
drove mass spec in toxicology laboratory
by 1980 although scientists
could ionize a small molecule
and measure them in mass spec they could
not
ionize large molecules like proteins
and other complex carbohydrates
without being breaking them
and fragment them in different pieces
in 1988 scientists
at different parts of the world and
almost
at the same time develop different
technologies
to ionize large molecules such as
proteins john fenn
and his team at yale university
discovered electron spray ionization
also kurishi tanata who was
an engineer at shimatsu company in japan
with the help of his research team
was able to successfully ionize
large proteins using laser
desorption
johnson and koichi tanaka
shared the nobel prize in chemistry
by 2002 and it was
given to them for their development
of soft desorption ionization method
for massive spectrometric analysis of
biological
macromolecule at the same time
that finn and tanaka were working
on protein ionization two german
scientists from the university of
frankfurt
franz healing camp and michael karas
were also working on protein ionizations
they use different technology called
laser microprobe
mass analyzer that helps them
successfully ionize large protein
molecules
they called their new technique
matrix assisted laser resorption
ionization
or maldi for short and published it
in 1985
these advancements made mass spec
much more user-friendly and
provided great opportunity to all
scientists to finally be able to
use this technology
without devoting their careers
working on different techniques
as i mentioned at the beginning of my
presentation
because of the time limitation i could
not cover the work of
all the great scientists who one way or
other contributed to the development
of mass spectrometry
i'm sorry that i wasn't able to mention
them all
it was not intentional i'd like to thank
you for your attention
and now i'll pass this to
my colleague dr jessica
boyd thank you thank you very much dr
sadie
so my section of the talk will be on the
basic principles of mass spectrometry
and the applications of this technology
in the clinical lab so this slide
just shows some of the applications that
mass spec is currently used
you can see that there are many
applications currently in use in
chemistry
and of course in microbiology mass spec
is used for bacterial identification
if you were to boil down mass spec to
its most basic components you can kind
of
put it into four different boxes which
i've put here
of course at the beginning you need
usually need to do some kind of sample
preparation
in order to clean up the matrix
concentrate the analyte or
put the sample into a form that can be
introduced into the mass spec
this can be done online or offline
then when the sample is ready we need to
ionize it so that it can be seen
by the mass analyzer the mass
analyzer itself is then able to filter
the ions so that we can control
which ones are actually hitting the
detector at any given time
which then provides us the data that is
so useful and that we would then analyze
and put in a form that is reportable to
physicians
i'm going to go through these three blue
boxes here very quickly over the next
few slides starting with sample
introduction
so this slide shows some of the
ionization types that are present in the
clinical lab and you'll see that i have
organized them by the state that the
sample is in
in the top line we have gas
chromatography typically here we're
using either electron impact or chemical
ionization
sources and the ei in particular has
been used
to great effect for analysis of drugs
obese in urine
liquid chromatography is really coming
into vogue in the clinical chemistry
laboratory and
in my lab for example this is what we're
using most commonly
coupled to an electrospray ionization
source
of course we have other options such as
an apci source
which are used for analytes that are
more lipophilic and perhaps don't ionize
as well with esi
and then finally we also have solid
state analysis and
a good example of this is maldi
so just to spend a minute on
electrospray ionization because it is so
prevalent
in clinical chemistry on the left is a
diagram of how esi works
you'll see on the very left that there's
a tube with liquid spraying out of it
and this is the esi capillary that is
coupled to the end of your lc
system in the mobile phase a modifier
and ph adjustments should be done so
that your analyte is ionized
and then a current or voltage can be
applied to the
esi capillary so that it nebulizes that
sample
forming droplets containing charges and
you can see that at the bottom of the
picture
then within the source drying gas and
heat can be applied
to evaporate the solvent so that
ultimately and ideally
what you have entering the mass spec are
single individual
desolvated ions
compared to maldi where we have a solid
sample
here in this picture you can see we have
our analyte
depicted with green circles and it's
embedded in an ionizable matrix which is
depicted by the blue circles
when a laser is pointed at this mixture
the ionizable matrix will ionize and it
will transfer its charge
to our analyte of interest so that it is
able to enter the mass spectrometer
and be analyzed
so now we'll move on to the mass
analyzers so it's important to remember
that mass analyzers
manipulate ions and so that's why we
need to make sure that we have
a good ionization source sitting in
front of our mass spec
there are many different types of mass
analyzers available each with their own
strengths and weaknesses
today i will only be able to touch on
quadrupole and time of flight
analyzers and we're also able to
put mass analyzers in series to form a
tandem mass spectrometer and this really
increases
options for the types of scans that we
can do to look at fragmentation patterns
and this really
gives mass spec its edge in terms of
having higher specificity
compared to other methods we might use
in the clinical chemistry laboratory
just to show how this fragmentation
patterns and
can be used to help identify analytes
here i'm showing a gc electron impact
spectra of cocaine now electron impact
is
a hard ionization source so we get
fragmentation
of the parent ion in the source and so
when all those ions move
to the mass analyzer you can see that we
have a mixture
of parent cocaine as well as very
fragments of cocaine
now we know that if we always apply the
same voltage in ei
that we're able to actually reproduce
this spectra every single time we do
that analysis
both in terms of what's produced and the
intensity of what's produced
and so for gcms this has been pivotal
in helping us produce libraries that can
then be used to help us
identify drugs for example in patient
samples
in lcms although we don't necessarily
have the same kind of library system
that we do for gc
you know that when you do your method
validation and you determine what a
collision energy is
for triple quad for example that if you
apply that same collision energy under
the same conditions every single time
you will be producing the same fragment
ions and intensities and we can use that
as an extra layer to help identify
compounds in our samples
so this is a picture of a quadrupole
mass analyzer and of course it gets its
name from the configuration of the four
rods
on which electrical fields are applied
so that we can affect the trajectory of
ions
through the rods in clinical labs and
particularly in my lab for example
we see this in a triple quadrupole
configuration and so there's a picture
here at the bottom of the slide
you can see that there are three
quadrupoles in series
the q1 and q3 are what we use as the
mass filter
and q2 is used as a collision cell so
that we can fragment
ions coming in from q1 the scan type
that we use
almost exclusively in many labs is
called multiple reaction monitoring
and using a triple quadrupole how that
would work is that in q1
we would select for the parent ion of a
particular
you know compound or drug for example we
would then send that into q2 and
fragment it with nitrogen or argon gas
and then in q3 we would select at least
two usually fragment ions that we would
then
monitor and send to the detector each of
these
combinations of a parent and a fragment
ion are called an mrm transition
and like i said we usually monitor at
least two of these for every analyte in
our method
to give you an idea of what that looks
like practically this is
um a snippet of one of our reports from
an lcm sms
mrm drug screen method that we run in my
lab
and this is for benzoyleconine which is
a major metabolite of cocaine
and so we have three pictures here
the first is a chromatogram of what we
would call our quantifier chromatogram
or a quantifier mrm transition and this
is a transition that we would have
identified during method validation as
often the highest intensity one but not
always
and so you can see at the top of that
box it says 290.1 to 168.1 so that is
the transition we're monitoring
and so our staff would look at this of
course assess the chromatography and the
retention time
to determine whether we think this is
acceptable to uh for benzoylecne
identification
but we don't stop there we would then go
to the second box
and this is actually an overlay of the
chromatograms from two
mrm transitions so again if you look at
the top of that box
you'll see our quantifier transition of
290.1 to 168.1
but you'll also see one in blue that is
290.1 to 105.1
and this is our qualifier mrm and we use
this as an extra confirmation
to determine whether our drug is
actually present in the sample
based on how we set up the software for
this particular
assay you can we've asked the software
to actually normalize
the two chromatograms so that if we have
a good match between the two they should
actually overlay
and it should actually look like one
line and that's actually what it looks
like here
if benzoylecane was not present in this
sample it would be quite clear
if there were because we would have two
lines
visible and they wouldn't overlay at all
we'd have different bumps and lumps and
things
this is also helpful to identify if you
have a coaluting compound
in your chromatogram or one of the
one of the mrm transitions so one of
these might appear to have a bump on it
that the other doesn't
and then of course in the third box we
have an mrm transition monitored for
our internal standard which in this case
is benzoyleconine d3
here's a picture of a time of flight
mass analyzer and so
the difference here is that it contains
a flight
tube where ions are actually going to
fly through
they'll go to the bottom and be
reflected by a reflectron and then come
back
and hit the detector which is on the
right hand side there
mass is measured in this analyzer um
based on the time it takes to do this
transit
and smaller ions are able to do this
faster than larger ones so by measuring
the time
of transit we are able to then calculate
the mass of that original ion
now of course toff is often coupled with
maldi
for use in the clinical microbiology lab
and so here's just a picture putting
that all together
you can see on the left we have our
sample culture which would then be mixed
with the blue matrix and then spot it
onto a maldi-tof sample plate
that plate if you then look in the
picture on the right can be introduced
into the tof instrument hit with the
laser beam
and then you can see the ions going
through the flight tube to the detector
there's also some other areas that are
interested in using maldi
for use in the clinical lab particularly
in histology
and so here's an example of where we
would be able to analyze tissue sections
on a slide
using maldi to add extra information in
terms of
protein composition and localization
within a slide
that would add extra information for the
pathologist in addition to other
conventional histology staining
so just to finish i wanted to go through
a few things that we found
very helpful to consider when
implementing new math specs in our lab
or new mass spec methods
off of course selection of the mass
analyzer will depend on what you want to
measure with it and the type of data
desired whether you want to do full
scans on everything or
a targeted approach may influence what
you would get
one of the major benefits of mass spec
is that you can analyze
many analytes together simultaneously
from one sample
however keep in mind that everything you
add to a method adds complexity
in terms of running the method
maintaining the method and doing the
data
analysis and so you need to determine
whether that's going to be useful or not
to do that
method validation is different than what
you would do for a general chemistry
analyzer and that's whether you're doing
it as a lab develop test or
evaluating a kit method from a company
and there will be more information on
that in the third part of the talk
staff training often takes longer as the
instruments in the data analysis are
more manual than automated chemistry
analyzers although we're now starting to
see some solutions to help
with particularly with the data analysis
and
finally don't forget about the post
analytical part interfacing to the
laboratory information system
can significantly improve your workflow
and your turnaround time and you should
always consider it
when putting a mass spec or a new method
into your lab
so with that i'm going to pass it off to
dr orton
okay thanks jessica
so hi my name is dennis orton i am the
clinical biochemist that oversees the
lcms testing lab uh in calgary
for apl and i'm going to focus this part
on my talk
uh primarily on lcms methods so jessica
reviewed quite a few
different applications but the lcms is
definitely
kind of the the workhorse of the of the
clinical lab at the moment so i thought
i would
just go over some of the applications
and quality metrics that we should be
monitoring there in
and as um you know these these kit
methods become available and i
lcms becomes available in more and more
labs i feel like it's really important
to focus on
uh you know the the vendor may be trying
to sell you a kit method with
if you've seen that if you've seen the
matrix you kind of understand what i
mean where
what they're selling you is the blue
pill but what you're actually getting
is the red pill and my my own personal
experience would lead me uh to take the
blue pill every time but yeah so we'll
just talk about some of the lcms
applications that
that we have in our lab
um okay so um
basically there's so many different
aspects of an lcms method that you can
measure you can measure every single
uh parameter of a peak you could ever
imagine you can look at
you know the asymmetry you can look at
the uh the retention times in the uh
whether or not it's tailing
peak width etc cetera but what quality
metrics should we
really be monitoring is kind of the the
big question
and so i'm i'm just going to run through
kind of some of the things that i've
found
in my experience that are the most
helpful and get the most bang for your
buck and
so within every run you're going to
always want to focus on on looking at
things like the retention time
the ion ratios that jessica was talking
about in the previous section
and then also there's things that are
important like the internal standard
peak area
pressure plots peak shape those are all
really important things to pay attention
to throughout the course of a single run
and i'll show you some examples of why
that's important and what you can do to
potentially
do something about it but then also day
to day we uh
we run some system suitability samples
you should track like your peak areas
uh you should look specifically at
whether or not the signal to noise ratio
is changing over the course of your
you know the age of your your method or
your column or your solvents
and then i'll talk a little bit about
the qc results that we're expecting
okay so setting yourself up for success
basically before you start any run
it's always important to run some system
suitability samples just
just running several consecutive
injections of a standard that was made
in pure solvent
it doesn't need to have any kind of
preparation
or anything like that it's just
basically checking to make sure your
system is functioning before you start
your run
we generally say within our lab
especially if you have a decent
uh run time you know if it's like a five
minute run time you should be able to
get 10
10 injections just to make sure your
system is actually up and functional but
you may want to do fewer than that if
you have a really long run time so some
of the metrics that we look at
retention time so if your retention time
is highly variable injection to
injection
you can look at whether or not your
columns decreasing degrading whether you
have the
the correct column on whether or not
your column's even connected so
sometimes you know you forget to
actually plug the column into the system
and so you don't waste an entire run
you can stop it now and go yeah forgot
about that and then do it
you can make sure your your solvents are
mixing well there's no major leaks
within the system so if you see a
retention time that's bouncing around
quite a bit then that's
that's definitely some sort of leak
somewhere in your system
the column equilibration is also really
important so if your solvents
aren't being given time to
re-equilibrate you may like if you have
a really
unstable retention time you may just
have to add you know 30 seconds on the
tail end of your method to make sure
that it
uh it actually equilibrates between
injections
uh the pressure plot is a hugely
important thing so this will actually
detect
things like minor leaks so a lot of the
time your retention time may actually be
stable
and reproducible even though there is a
small leak somewhere and i find that you
know things like purge valves can get
loose and those kinds of things so
it's really important to kind of track
what your pressure currently is when
you're starting
and this is something that you'll you'll
find when you're setting up the method
in the lab that this is something you
have to
you have to actually monitor day to day
and make sure that you know
if your back pressure does increase over
time you could have you know
dirty lines or plug guard columns that
kind of stuff and that can affect your
chromatography and so
all you have to do is just switch out
the guard column or or flush a line and
you get
better signal intensity
um so the other things with your system
suitability so we actually track our
signal intensity day to day
and this helps kind of not only monitor
the the chromatography but also the
solvents themselves so if you only run a
method once a week then
you know your solvents can go bad real
quick uh your column can degrade which
can cause issues
uh the mass spec stability is big
especially after if you have to do
things like auto tunes or calibrations
or whatever periodically it's important
to kind of understand
how your signal to noise is changing
over time
also any like vacuum leaks ion transfer
issues
voltage applications these kinds of
things are all kind of things that
you have to worry about when you're
running method
so system suitability sample can look
many different ways so if i pretend like
this is a a situation where i've just
i'm just injecting a series of system
suitability samples over and over and
over again within the same batch
and if you see some sort of transition
of peak from nice
nice and pretty and sharp and good
retention time to more blobby and then
finally
the signal just basically drops off and
you got nothing
so this could indicate anything from
column degradation to loss and
performance
usually this is going to be a solvent
mismatch or a lack of column
equilibration so again just give it a
little bit more time in between
um your your actual gradient and the re
the next injection
this can also be caused by a back
pressure increase so if you have
injected a
sample and it's kind of cruddy your
system suitability sample should be made
up in a matrix that's very similar to
the solvent that you're actually running
through your system at the time so if
you're injecting
you know pure methanol and it could
cause you know precipitation of
of your of your solvents or your buffers
and your solvents during
something along those lines within your
system which can plug it and cause these
kinds of problems
so it's just really important to kind of
you can see these kinds of things coming
like you could actually stop
it at you know in the middle pane here
so if you have your nice sharp peak
normally and then you see that it's kind
of blobby and no good
you don't have to wait for you know the
tenth injection of the system
suitability to stop it and
do some intervention and actually get
get to it in a timely way
so conversely you can have the exact
same pattern of uh
of the peak areas but with a nice pretty
peak
um and so this again can it's usually
related to solvents or
columns uh improper sample preparation
it could be
something wrong with your injection
valve or there's a
small leak somewhere in the system
that's causing your your sample not to
not get efficient
efficiently loaded onto the onto the
column so this one is an especially
frustrating situation if your peak
still looks good but your peak area is
completely dropped off it can be
extremely frustrating to try to
troubleshoot that but
generally it's going to be something
like your solvent ph is not stable or
it could be the the mass spec itself is
it's got a vacuum leak somewhere
it could be the um the samples not being
injected properly and those kinds of
things you have to check into
so when you're monitoring the internal
standard over the course of the run
and this is this is very important to
kind of derive what your acceptability
criteria
are during validation and i'm not
this it's not it's kind of without the
scope of this talk for me to talk about
how to validate how to set up a mass
effect method as a lab developed test my
focus is more
the quality metrics that you should be
trying to keep track of
both during clinical validation as well
as during
operation so you kind of have to come up
with some acceptability criteria for
your internal standard
uh injection to injection um to track
your chromatographic consistency
to track whether or not you have trends
or issues with your with your sample
especially in the absence of analyte
so this is really important for things
like drugs and abuse testing where
you're not going to have
drugs not every patient sample you're
testing has all of the drugs in your
panel all the time
so it's really important to have
internal standards kind of scattered
throughout your
your chromatogram so you can actually
make sure that your solvents are mixing
well and your your sample is being
injected properly those kinds of things
you really do have to make specific note
of your calibrators and qc material and
i'll show you an example of why that is
in a moment
but matrix effects can really alter your
extraction efficiency or your ion
suppression profile so
if you're running your calibrators and
they're not representative of your
patients then you really have to
question what you're actually doing with
your sample prep
you can see variation in this in the
internal standard
due to iron suppression or
chromatographic problems
generally it's important to make note of
this during your validation again and
i'll talk about this in a moment
is if your internal standard is being
suppressed
by your by your parent molecule then
it's very important to kind of
understand like if your target analyte
overlaps with your internal standard as
it as it should
um that you're going to see some
suppression of your internal standard
when you're
when your target molecule is quite high
in abundance so it's just very important
to understand how your asset actually
functions because that would be a part
of your linearity experiment
okay so further on to the internal
standards so basically
what i showed you before was an okay
example this is a bad example of what an
internal standard should not
look like so trends are highly
undesirable and this is something that
i've encountered
several times in my current lab where we
have
just some minor ongoing issues that need
to be cleaned up so
if you see something like you can see
here in the first 10 injections or so
these are the calibrators and qc
material and then
from injection number 10 on and this is
in the left panel
you can see that it's highly variable
the internal standard response is all
over the place
but there's also kind of a trend start
to finish it starts high and ends low
and when i pulled the data i found that
this was actually reproducible run to
run day-to-day batch to batch
and everybody just kind of accepted this
as normal
but it is not it's basically bad
practice because you've got
you know your calibrators are running
different than your than your patient
samples obviously
but there's also something obviously
different with your patient samples or
something
something you're injecting in your
patient samples that's causing
differences
in your chromatography over time and
then when you see on the right panel
um this abnormal this you should have
seen this coming like people were
shocked that this happened
no no you needed to see this coming from
your day-to-day
monitoring of your internal standard
response you know that it's dropping
over time and then just all of a sudden
one day you have precipitation on the
column or your guard column gets plugged
or whatever and that causes this problem
but
the main thing is if this is what your
internal standard pattern looks like you
really do have to address it using
either
sample preparation different
chromatography
something along those something is wrong
and so it's important to address it
before you have
such a big problem as you see on the
right the question of can qc help
um of course yeah qc can help but how
often to run it really depends on lots
of different factors
uh how many repeats your lab can
tolerate if something goes wrong is a
big thing
so if you're running a 10 minute drug
screen method then
obviously you want to run your qc a
little bit more maybe a little bit more
often because you don't want to have to
repeat
you know dozens of patient samples at 10
minutes a run
if it's a 2 minute run you maybe can run
your qc a little bit
more flexibly um the biggest question is
does the quantitative result actually
reflect the underlying problem
like the what problems you're actually
trying to
like figure out here if you're if you're
tracking just the the quality control
quantitative results then it's important
to kind of keep in the back your mind
that you're not actually looking at what
could be the actual problem
so when you're troubleshooting your qc
failures that's something that you
definitely need to pay attention to
the arbitrary recommendation is that you
run uh qc every 10 patient specimens i
think this comes from
uh basically glp practices um
and there's no real reason for it other
than
uh it's a good number it's a nice round
number and it seems like it works pretty
well but
again if you have a highly uh
if you have a very high throughput
method every every two minutes
you're injecting a new patient sample
and maybe you don't quite need to do it
every 10 patient specimens and maybe
even the beginning middle and end
and again does your qc actually reflect
patient specimens so
if you have a lab prepared qc
that maybe has a little bit more organic
solvent in there because that's how you
had to make it
and you have a very different uh
recovery from your qc than you do from
your patient samples
you kind of have to ask yourself that
question if your qc is not reflecting
your patient samples
then running it periodically does that
really change anything
it's also really common to run a
calibration curve at the beginning and
end of an lcms
batch and this will kind of let you know
if there's big differences in
chromatographic performance or lcms
performance or whatever but
between between runs and or within the
run
and that's really important i think but
the question of which calibration curve
do you use when they're
when they're different um that's one of
those things where you kind of have to
address that during your validation your
clinical validation
and come up with the the acceptability
criteria and in that case you would have
to use your qc that you've run
throughout your batch
so onto ion ratios so ion ratios are the
classic triple quad
quality metric as jessica mentioned this
is like your fingerprint right so if i
have the right retention time the right
ion ratio
the right peak shape all as well i can
say with high confidence that this is
indeed
benzoylecognine for example but the
acceptability criteria generally use
peak area and peak area can be
influenced by a number of different
factors so
if you have an overlapping peak uh some
interference that's overlapping with
your analyte of interest and you see
your qualifier peak is way higher
than your quantifier and it shouldn't be
then obviously that's an interference
that's a problem
but whether or not that's a suppression
of your quantifier and an increase of
your qualifier or vice versa
is a question you kind of have to
address and
um that's that's kind of its own problem
because i don't think that
modifying a chromatogram would actually
get rid of this you may have to address
this during sample prep
what's more common is you get these
shoulders on your qualifier
and the dangerous thing about this is if
you just rely on the iron
or the uh the iron ratio itself with the
peak area ratio
then you may actually miss this because
these
areas may actually turn out to be just
coincidentally the same as your your
analyte of interest but clearly there's
something overlapping there
and that's going to be a problem so
really use of ion ratios requires an
understanding
of your expected peak shape for both the
quantifier and the qualifier
uh it's possible to still report the
result
if only the qualifier is affected by
this interference
but you really do have to do a little
bit more checking into that and that may
require you know repeat testing uh new
extractions checking your solvents etc
etc
if failure is common you may want to
look at uh adjusting your sample
preparation or
chromatography like use a new column uh
have a confirmation method
those kinds of things but if all else
fails you can actually add a second or
third qualifying ion
that can be used when the primary ion
fails and again all you have to do is
just run through and make sure that
these kinds of interferences
don't don't overlap with all of those
those
secondary third tertiary kind of quality
or
qualifier ions
so the question about external quality
assurance
or proficiency testing um obviously this
is just the same as any other
uh any other assay any other chemistry
assay uh prevents drift over time due to
unidentified changes in your assay
performance so
just make sure you're not wandering too
far from the peer group
pretty much all your stereotypical pt
providers have
lcms options um cap lgc
one world are a few of the providers
that i've used
but you'll notice if you've been running
these things acceptability criteria are
often very what i'm going to call
friendly so the the uh criteria are not
very stringent
um and so that's something you kind of
keep in the back your mind like
really if you are doing your own
internal quality checks
sufficiently if you're checking your lot
to lot variation in your calibrators in
your qc you should never really
fail but the number one failure we do
have is
matching units and so because we are in
canada and lots of those
proficiency testing labs are in or in
the u.s
we have to convert our units and we
always you know miss a
miss a decimal or don't carry a one or
whatever
and so this is where coming in it's
really important to set your
acceptability criteria around
preparation of calibrators
or even bringing in external um you know
like
commercially available calibrators and
qc material it's a good idea to get them
either separate lots or from different
vendors whether or not you're making
them yourself
or or not it's not really important it's
important to get as much variability in
there as you can so that you really
aren't reliant on a single vendor
wherever possible to be able to catch
if there's any changes in your
chromatographic or lcms performance over
time
so just a a note on the validation
i don't want to go too deep into this
because again this isn't really a
focus on on the validation side so
there's clsi guidelines available for
clinical method validation so
these things cover pretty much
everything you can desire
um but for lcms a clinical method
validation and i'm not talking about the
development side with
you know picking your ions and
everything like that i'm talking about
um
the the clinical side so you really do
just need to
shift your focus a little you do the
same exact experiments as you do with
any other clinical method evaluation
whether like it's
a ammonia or ast but
you have to focus differently and so
this is going to be shifting focus onto
the peak areas
the reproducibility thereof so when you
do your linearity experiments you want
to make sure that your internal standard
peak area is
is not being suppressed too much you can
purposely adjust your internal standard
peak area
to to compensate for that and actually
shift your linear
range if you need to you have to focus
on matrix effects obviously
during manual sample prep there's a lot
of issues surrounding that
and iron suppression experiments um
using the post column infusion
is a good way to go about that um
precision experiments so this is going
to have to uh it's very important to
kind of focus on both your peak area as
well as your
your quantitative results so if you have
an internal standard
and an analyte that behave differently
during your extraction
then your precision experiment needs to
look at the the difference in your
peak areas and so when you see a high cv
a percent tv of the analytical result uh
that may actually just be a
due to your internal standard ratio is
just completely off because your
internal standard is inappropriate or
not or it's being suppressed
differently something along those lines
so that's where you need to focus with
your
with your precision experiments uh
limited detection is actually your kind
of your stereotype so there's no real
difference there
but it is really important to kind of
just keep in the back your mind that you
don't want your zero your your
background noise to exceed 20 percent of
your
your peak area uh for your low sample
and that's just kind of a general rule
the interference is there's less focus
on on the in serum indices and more
focus on isobaric compounds drugs
unexpression that kind of stuff
and so that's pretty much the gist of my
talk so
i hope i've convinced you that quality
metric monitoring is vital to
understanding the performance your assay
but
when i came into my lab there was a lot
of uh
aversion to using the technology
basically because they weren't
familiar with it there's a lot of
hand-waving arguments that kind of come
up with
oh that that internal standard just
dropped off because
i needed to you know gut the instrument
and change all the lines and
and you know everything like that but
well no you just needed to alter your
sample preparation so it's just
it's really important to kind of
understand how your assay is performing
before you
go live with it clinically and
understand and have all your staff
understand
uh that as well so that you don't end up
with these kind of
biases against the technology or these
these what i would call extreme
troubleshooting measures for simple
problems
so with sample with adequate sample
preparation and foresight lcms methods
should be able to be incorporated to
pretty much any workflow
so i've i've worked in a hospital lab i
work in a reference lab now and
the lcms was applicable to both
different tests obviously but
it is actually it's doable it's just you
really do have to reinforce those those
differences between those high
volume chemistry analyzers and and the
lcms system
and you know lcms expansion is happening
so
understanding what these metrics are and
how to use them clinically is more
important than i would say
ever so i guess there's really just one
acknowledgement here is heather paul
helped construct some of these slides
but i really did want to go out of my
way to say thank you to the waters
corporation and lab roots for having us
i'm excited and hopefully this was an
informative situation
and i guess i will open it up to
questions
thank you very much dr sausage dr orton
dr boyd for your informative information
uh presentation sorry um we're now going
to start the live q a portion of this
webinar
um if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please please
do so now just click the ask a question
box located in the far left of your
screen we already have several questions
that have come in
um but we will answer as many of the
questions that have come in as we have
time for
before we answer these questions we do
have a couple of poll questions that are
going to be sent out to you now
um and while that's happening i'm going
to go ahead and get started with our
first questions
so um i think i'm going to start with a
question that came
in about the identification of new
synthetic illegal drugs
this is a topic in toxicology that comes
up
quite often so maybe dr boyd you can
give us your experience on
synthetic synthetic illegal drugs and
measurement of those
sure yeah so of course these are um
a very tricky group because they're of
course changing so quickly
that everybody really struggles to try
and keep up with them
you know some of these groups we see you
know 10
12 new variants show up every year
and you know every few months and so
it's really quite tricky to keep up with
them
um because by the time you know we
validate a method uh clinically
and of course usually these are lab
developed tests as uh
dennis was talking about um it takes
time for the lab to catch up and by the
time we have usually they've gone to a
new
a new uh variant of that drug making
us have to go back to the beginning and
start everything again so
um so it's definitely tricky um
typically uh probably the
technique that's used the most or the
strategy is
is using high resolution mass
spectrometry
which we didn't spend a ton of time on
today but
essentially gathering as much
information about that sample as
possible in an untargeted fashion
and i know for example here in alberta
our medical examiner will do that
using a tof instrument and take those
scans
and then save them and so that later on
when a new drug is
uh you know identified or you know we
hear about it on a list server or
something
they can go back and search those uh old
uh
spectra and look to see if those drugs
were actually there we just didn't know
that they were there at the time or we
hadn't you know identified them as a new
synthetic drug
so it's definitely um it's definitely a
huge problem
probably something like i said that
high-res mass spec is is more
able to deal with than perhaps the mrm
triple quad information that we're using
for some of our other assays
but it's going to be a continuous
problem
like i said because there's just more
and more of these coming out all the
time and it's hard for us to
keep up yes
i i can imagine all right thank you for
that
um the next question that i have here
is um regarding uh the fixation time and
sample age affect mass spec based
recognition of peptides and cancer
histology applications
uh dr orton
uh hi yeah um so i can basically i
should
say this with a qualifying statement
saying that i've never actually done
this um
clinically uh but i know that when
you're doing things like proteomic
analysis
uh or genomic analysis when you're
trying to extract rna
or or dna from from fixed tissue the
fixation time does
influence it does influence how how well
you can actually get analytes out uh but
you can
you can probably work that out during
the uh the antigen retrieval type method
that you're using
like whatever whatever method you're
using to wash off the
the paraffin or or remove the the
formula or anything like that you can
probably adapt your
your procedure that way to make it more
robust and less
influenced by the fixation process
great thank you and while you're on the
phone i still i have another question
for you
um a question came in that someone gets
interference for steroids when patients
are on supplements despite sample
preparation
uh is there any ideas how to deal with
that
steroids are tricky um i think that what
what some people say to do is to have uh
other multiple multiple chromatographic
methods or you can have different
columns
uh if you can kind of redevelop or
co-develop the method
uh using a separate column like a column
chromatograph or a column chemistry
then that would theoretically at least
separate out the uh the interferences
at least differently than your than your
routine method
[Music]
yeah thank you i'm
sorry we've got a lot of questions
coming in so i'm trying to
get through them all um
the next question i have is the
association of 3d gels with maldi tough
ms a technique and disuse
i guess i could probably take that one
too so i come from a proteomics
background
i did uh discovery based shotgun
proteomics for my uh for my
project for my phd i used 2d gels
using basically the isoelectric focusing
along the top and then the uh the
gel-based separation the scs page-based
separation on the uh
along the other axis um i think
the the the movement is to go towards
more of a
mud pit technology uh and then so that
basically allows you to label your
sample
uh using the the tandem mass tags and
you can do quantitative analysis that
way
uh the the gel based analysis used to
use basically differential staining so
you would use like a
like a green tag on one and a red tag on
another and then
you could see the differences in the gel
itself and then you could
excise those those spots and do a
multi-top analysis and get an idea of
what was different
but i would say that technology is
indeed in disuse
and that quantitative proteomics is kind
of shifting more towards
the the mud pit peptide peptide based
methods
thank you another question
um about how to deal with ion
suppression problems for most abundant
proteins
and phospholipids in serum for targeted
analysis
do you need to perform immunocapture or
spin column
lots of lots of proteomics based
questions here um
yes probably uh so the most commonly
used proteomic method in
clinical uh in the clinical lab maybe
not the most common but the most
difficult uh that that i know of is
thyroglobulin which is a
enormous protein then you have to digest
it and actually you use what's called a
ciscapa
approach that's a stable isotope uh
enriched um i can't remember the name of
the acronym at the moment
um but basically use an antibody that's
targeted against the peptide
after you do your trips and digestion so
you're not enriching the protein you're
enriching the peptide
and i think that provides you a lot more
specificity in the clinical method
development
in the um in the more discovery based
proteomics yeah spin columns are
available you can deplete
uh high abundance proteins you can do
molecular weight cutoff filters
differential
precipitation those kinds of things get
rid of all the immunoglobulins
there's various strategies to try to
deal with that but the ciscapa
is probably the most common in the in
the clinical lab because you do get the
most specificity
from that great thank you
um i guess we'll continue for a couple
more questions i know it's getting late
but
um what type of instrument instrument
variability would you expect to see when
monitoring internal standard areas
um i guess that's that's me again unless
jessica do you want to answer that one
no go ahead it's your part of the talk
okay
um i i don't know if there's a there's a
solid answer to this because there's
always subtle variation between
uh different instruments so we do have
uh
paired analyzers in our in our lab and
we but we don't quantify the difference
between the internal standard
responses i think it's important to kind
of keep that in back your mind that
you're
when you're validating your analyzer you
have to keep in mind the specific uh
performance of that one analyzer i would
never
try to take the peak area from one and
compare it to another that said they
should be
similar you know you should be within
the same ballpark i'm not going to say
within 5
or 10 i'm going to say you know they
should be at least
they should perform kind of the same way
between the two analyzers when you're
looking at your analyte
response ratios so it's kind of hard to
answer that question
uh specifically i would say that they
need to be similar but not the same
right great thank you um so dr boyd why
is multi-multiple reaction monitoring
used in
so prevalently prevalently but i can't
talk in clinical chemistry assays
yeah i think um part of the reason that
it's used so prevalently for chemistry
is that it
is a really strong technique for doing
what we would call targeted analysis and
i kind of alluded to this
in the last uh question that was asked
but
um often you know you can think about
running your maths back in a targeted
way in that you know what you're looking
for
and you can tell the instrument just to
look for those things or you can run it
in an untargeted where we're just trying
to collect as much information across
the whole sample as possible
you know there's advantages either way
in the case of those
uh you know emerging drugs of abuse it
you know is potentially more useful to
collect all of that information to try
and make sure we don't miss anything
but for many of the analytes that we're
doing in chemistry
we know what analyte we want to look at
and you know therefore we know the
molecular weight and
or should be able to figure out its
fragmentation pattern during method
validation
and so by running an mrm we're able to
really you know
up the specificity because we are
looking at that that uh fragment
transition
um but also um you know help reduce some
of that background noise because we
tell the instrument only to look at
certain things
um and um so for things like you know
our metanephrons assay you know we know
we're looking for metanephrine or
metanephrine we don't necessarily care
about all the other stuff in the sample
so
um i think that's one of the one of the
strengths the other thing is of course
once you
kind of have one method running an mrm
then you um
you know it's it's perhaps not as much a
leap for staff to understand what you're
doing
um uh if you run another mrm even if
it's for a very different
um uh analyte class such as a tdm or
something like that so
um and then third of course you can do
that kind of scan mode very
um i guess uh easily or efficiently on
something like a triple quad which of
course puts
the instrumentation in a price point
that many labs now are able to
uh to purchase that kind of
instrumentation rather than going for
something that's um maybe overpowered
for the analysis that you want to do
perfect thank you um i think i want to
take one last question
um because we are quite over time and
the questions that we didn't get to we
will
we will answer them i promise you uh we
will do that by email with the email
that you sent to us but
last question is going to be more of an
educational question uh for dr saturday
of the four scientists develop um the
methods for ionization of large
molecules at the same time
why if sorry if the four scientists
developed the methods
for ionization of large molecules at the
same time
why did only two of the scientists
receive the nobel prize
thank you ben this is a question that
actually
has been on the minds of many scientists
in the field
indeed many of the
[Music]
recognized chemists especially in europe
who were invited to the noble
uh did not go and the reason they didn't
go they
said that the
prize nobel prize went to the wrong
address they meant he should have gone
to
dr helen kent and
his colleague dr karas in germany
uh but the uh i'm gonna
quote dr norden
who was the chairman of the nobel prize
committee for chemistry
and he said that tanaka was
honored because he was the first
to develop an idea that
changed other people's way of thinking
there are other people who also said
that tanaka
did not only
[Music]
invent a new way of ionization
it was all he was he also invented
the way to really set up the instrument
adjusting the detector it wasn't just
the ionization
but in general i should say
that many people were upset and the
maori
the method that was developed by dr
helen kam
and paris has been used
far more than the method that was
developed
by dr kanaka thank you
thank you very much dr saturday all
right so
um i i would like to thank the audience
for joining us today
i again we will get to the rest of the
questions that are in here
but we are running a little bit over
time um
but i would like to thank you for your
your attendance and the interesting
questions and your engagements
um i'd also like to thank our presenters
for their time today
and this important um research
we also like to thank lab roots in
association with uh here with us here at
waters corporation for underwriting
today's educational webcasts
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
it
that email with your colleagues and
anybody who missed
uh today's live event thank you again to
our presenters and thank you to you for
for joining us today